you know my feelings I think it exactly
the same as laws of everybody else
across the country you know today's all
and I still feel stunned and just
overwhelmingly sad about what happened
to Joe I didn't know her personally but
absolutely everything I've read about
and heard about her since Thursday makes
me wish desperately that I had no know
she appears to have been everything that
you would want an elected representative
to be passionate and committed somebody
driven by belief and conviction hugely
energetic and very accessible to the
public which we all try to be and that
accessibility of course is one of the
hallmarks of our democracy and something
we must not allowed to be undermined but
above all else and more important than
all of that jewel was a mom of two young
children and you know I'm not the only
one far from being the only one whose
heart just breaks every time I think of
those kids just know and I suppose the
the comfort is knowing that they all
grew up knowing just what a wonderful
person their mother was and how proud of
her they should be in everybody else
should be over and you think part of our
legacy could be you you talked to didn't
you about a new beginning for our
politics flowing from this could you
just expand on that well I know how I
feel personally and I have felt personal
in these last couple of days it's you
know as a politician you know I feel
inspired by her example to to rededicate
myself to politics and public service as
a force for good you know all too often
people vilify and criticize politicians
and and much of that is perfectly
legitimate with public servants we are
there to be held to account and that's
right and proper but we're also in the
overwhelming majority of cases people
who come into politics for the right
reasons we you know if this isn't too
much of a cliche we come into politics
because in our different ways we want to
make the world a better place and I
think I will not be alone and wanting to
rededicate myself to that but I also
hope that part of Joy's legacy will be
you know a political discourse that is
perhaps a less vitriolic can
cruel and less harsh you know I I don't
think from what I know or have learned
about or what I've read about I don't
think she would want us to become less
passionate and how we debate politics
but perhaps she would want us to be more
respectful and recognize that our
political opponents by and large are
just that opponents with a different
view of how we make the world a better
place
nor enemies who are badly motivated and
if that can lead to a more respectful
discourse then that will be one aspect
of what I am sure will be a huge and
very positive legacy of Joe Cox okay let
me ask you about the upcoming vote we're
all aware of on the UK's place inside or
or outside the European Union now you've
talked didn't you last week about
putting contingency plans in place for
Scotland what are they well I think you
would expect me as First Minister of
Scotland to be looking at all
eventualities and making sure that we
are planning for those eventualities
I've said you know I'll see again today
what I've said a million times if
Scotland votes to stay in the European
Union and you know what I'm about to see
is predicated on Scotland voting to the
end although I don't take that for
granted but if we then face the prospect
of been taken out of the EU against
their will then of course we would have
to look at all options to protect a
relationship with the European Union and
give effect to how the Scottish people
had voted and our manifesto for the
Scottish elections that we fought the
election on just last month said that
one option that the Scottish Parliament
should have the right to consider is
another independence referendum so I'm
not seeing anything there that have not
said a million times before but I will
also see again today and I've said this
often before too I hope this scenario
doesn't arise I fervently and
passionately hope that people right
across the UK and in every part of the
UK vote to remain in the European Union
and not just because I think that will
be better for our economy for jobs and
treat all those staying part of the what
would single biggest the biggest single
market will certainly be all of that but
it's also I think a big and a
fundamental decision about the kind of
world we want to be part of I want to be
living in a country part of a world
where independent
Nations choose to work together we will
open an outward-looking and inclusive
and I think I've ought to leave the EU
would be a vote to be that caused and
inward-looking and I don't think that's
right for the UK or any part of the UK
but if it is a vote to leave and whether
Scotland votes over all in or out then
negotiations have to start and would
you're feeling be that it couldn't just
be UK representatives UK officials doing
that because there are so many now
devolved powers that the Scottish
Parliament has that there would have to
be Scottish officials specifically
Scottish officials negotiating on some
of those details oh absolutely the
Scotland's voice would have to be heard
and and here'd directly and in those
circumstances I'm very clear about that
but you know in a very strong sense
these are discussions for after Thursday
and I hope the discussions that don't
have to happen because I'll go back to
the central point and we're still a few
days away from pulling D I think it's
really important that those of us who
want to see a remain vote those of us
who want to see the UK and all of the
nations in the UK s the part of Europe's
the part of the world C outward-looking
and open and inclusive make that case
and that's what I'll be doing over these
next few days and I very much hope that
what we see on Thursday is a strong vote
for me not just in Scotland but England
Wales Northern Ireland as well as well
yeah yeah and where will you be doing
that campaigning mr. Jinnah as you no
doubt know a pretty popular south of the
border as well you're going to be making
any forays south in the next few days
I've been so to the border in the last
couple of weeks as you may know I took
part in a debate at UK weight and was in
London at the end of last week er I
don't plan to be south of the border for
the remainder of the campaign I'll be
campaigning in Scotland this week and
I'll be very strongly making the case
that people in Scotland should vote to
remain and I hope that message will be
one that's relevant to and will resonate
with people right across the Yukiya I
think there are and you know I would say
to people you don't have to believe
everything that David Cameron or the UK
tragedy says here I think you know as
First Minister I look at the evidence my
judgment is that economically socially
culturally we're better
remaining as part of the EU you know we
live in a world that is increasingly
interdependent I'm a nationalist I've
watched Scotland to be independent but I
believe with everything I've got that in
the world we live in independent
countries much reach out and work
together I don't want the UK to the N
word looking and to close itself off and
the other point I would make is and
these last few days I hope we can have a
debate that doesn't focus on immigration
yes people's concerns about immigration
need to be addressed but let's also make
the positive case for a word Alden and a
Europe where we all have the freedom of
travel and the positive case for
immigration and the benefits that bring
it to our economy and I would say you
know on that point that the poster that
Nigel Farage unveiled last week was vile
and racist no no you're going to be
speaking to him later on and I hope he
does agree today to withdraw that poster
because that kind of sentiment has no
place in a civilized debate so you want
me to tell him it's vile and racist in
in your opinion was it not though
touching on people's concerns about the
overall number of people who come
through the email and might make their
way to the European that might make
their way to the UK though be clearer I
don't take the view that people who have
concerns about immigration or resis
that's not what I'm seeing I do think
Nigel Farage's poster was racist but my
argument of immigration is if you have
concerns about the impact of immigration
I'm sitting here in Glasgow actually my
own constituency a couple of miles from
here there's a part of my constituency
where there's a real impact from recent
Eastern European immigration but my
argument is let's deal with the Empire
let's invest and housing in public
services rather than blame immigrants or
at take out a view that we should
somehow close our borders in what
migration is good for our economy you
know you hear the leaf campaign saying
we've got record levels of inward
migration we've also got record high
levels of employment across the UK right
now economies that are open and
welcoming inclusive are generally
speaking more successful than those that
closed themselves or with no limits
minister it might get from this to the
EU maker well you know it's not the case
that we don't have controls on
immigration some of those controls they
I think leak to cases like one we've got
in Scotland
now we're a a couple and their child
from Australia came here under the post
study work visa rules with an
expectation of being able to see those
rules were changed and though they face
the prospect of having to even get a
massive contribution to make the point
I'm making is less of a balanced and
proper debate about immigration not one
in which people's legitimate concerns
are exploited in a way that is designed
to encourage people to turn inwards
that's what the leave leadership I think
have been doing and I think it is deeply
regrettable and lastly if I were a an
SNP voter living in Scotland listening
to what you've said mr. Jim well some of
them be drawing the conclusion given
what you said about Scotland's
relationship with the European Union
wouldn't some of them being draw the
conclusion that on first they would have
the best perhaps to vote no or to
abstain because then you would get a
step closer perhaps to another
independence referendum know what
there's no logic to that at all you know
what am i vote for remain on Thursday
will not be driven by considerations
about what it means for an independent
Scotland day you know I believe in an
independent Scotland but my vote for
Ramin will be a but many other reasons
but what I'm saying to people who
perhaps support independence who are
considering their vote in Thursday based
on what they think it means for Scottish
independence if Scotland votes leave
then that premise for independence isn't
there you know if Scotland votes to
remain and facies been taken out or
viewed up against their will then yes I
think the option of a second
independence referendum has to be on the
table for consideration but that
arguments not leave Scotland also votes
to leave if Scotland votes to leave and
there's a leave all across the whole of
the UK then our immediate future is
Scotland in the UK out of Europe facing
a UK government led by the likes of
Boris Johnson that if it's possible to
believe this would be even more right
wing than that led by David Cameron and
George Osborne that's not the kind of
situation I want to see arise so if
that's your consideration as a an
independent supporter then the only
logical thing to do is to vote remain
First Minister great talking to you
thank you very much indeed for your time
Nicholas
thank you very much